I see women in America and mid-length
skirts I could see women in Liberia
we're in middling skirts too
in Liberia most women wear laka outfits
they wear to church and they wear it to
formal occasions I want a girl in a
bombshell skirt going to the market to
buy eggs and tomatoes we want to offer a
woman something to feel a little bit
more confident a little bit more sexy a
little more fun and flirty
neither so well so I'm happy because I
came here I know nothing
so none rattle so let's have tools we
want to be seen as a fashion brand we
know that people aren't buying from us
because of duty purchases we know people
think our clothes are really dope and
they can see themselves in it